The David Pakman show, sub reddit@davidpakman.com
a slash r e d d I t now has nearly 13,000
of our viewers and listeners participating
in political discussion and suggesting ideas
for the show. Couple of things that caught
my eye this morning. A very interesting post
saying, Hey David, can you interview crazy
people again, some of your best material online
is the classic interviews with the Anti Gay
religious crowd. I think I heard you say times
are different now and there'd be no point
in interviewing these people.
I beg you though, please, at least once a
month to interview a loony a, I'm up for this.
You know, really the problem we've been having
is we're having a hard time finding loonies
that are number one, able to be coherent enough
that you can even have like a conversation
because with a lot of these folks you just
introduced them and then it's 20 minutes of
ranting and raving and we just get nowhere.
Uh, and also finding ones that are, that are
sort of even mildly relevant. So if there
are particular extremists or Wacky folks that
you want me to interview, I am more than willing
to do some of those interviews like we used
to do on the show. It's just a matter of finding
the right people. Let me know who you think
might meet the minimum criteria for me to
do that.
But we're more than glad to book those folks
on the show. If you don't want me to do that,
also let me know. That would be interesting
to hear. Another post linking to cold James
Caches appearance on the Jesse Lee Peterson
show. I, this might be inside baseball and
if it is, I apologize, but Jesse Lee Peterson
is a pro Trump anti black pro white black
conservative who's program I appeared on in
Los Angeles when I was there, uh, six months
ago or so, seven, eight months now, nine months.
May Be wow. Time flies. Um, and he recently
interviewed a, an individual named Cole James
Cash. I don't really want to spoil anything
about the appearance for you, but let me just
say this. You should watch all of it and it's
under two minutes long because the guy got
kicked off much like I've previously been
kicked off of Jesse Lee Peterson's show.
So check that out and you can find it on the
David Pakman show, sub reddit@davidpakman.com
slash r e. D d. I. T. A help us get to 13,000
subscribers on the subreddit. That would be
delightful.